what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time well while
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
just trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
pelina evilo marinova pompano p-i-m-p
looking like an angel
in all white don't worry i got on the
uniform we're all good don't forget
also that lunch money is now sponsored
by block five block five has three
products you can buy and sell crypto you
can deposit crypto and earn up to eight
point six percent apy in an
interest-bearing account
or you can deposit crypto and take out a
us dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
i'm an investor i sit on the board i'm a
happy user and you will be
too if you get a block fi account at
blackfy.com
dot com let's do it i think i need a
haircut
maybe we have eight minutes and we're
going to rip through this ready
set fed chairman jerome powell
said that policy will need to be
patiently accommodative as the jobs
market continues to heal
despite an unemployment rate that has
fallen to 6.3 percent
the same central bank leaders said the
employment picture is a long
way from where it needs to be powell
noted that the actual unemployment rate
is probably considered
10 and said the fed needs to stay
focused on its broad and
broad and inclusive employment goal i
got three points
one he's admitting that the official
numbers are false
yeah why is that because they know
they're false but they
keep reporting them even though they
know they're false so the number
official number is six percent
unemployed but he's saying that it's
probably ten so why don't we report the
official numbers it's
baloney two is that him and janet yellen
are going to continue to weaken the
dollar at
a time where they're going to try to get
to full employment it is
nonsense they're going to drive higher
levels of inflation it's going to punish
people who save and it's going to reward
people who invest
so rather than complain about it make
sure you're investing not saving your
money
third do these people think we're stupid
they literally think we're dumb they
come out
they're literally trying to slip and oh
it's not six percent it's really ten
percent
oh that must also mean that the
inflation number is not real so
maybe the official numbers are
all garbage garbage as my friend kevin
o'leary likes to say garbage
so don't believe the numbers because
they're not right and they're now
admitting that they're not right but
they're going to keep reporting them as
if they're right
but they're not so be smart think for
yourself and don't listen to this
nonsense
jack dorsey is donating one million
dollars to crypto think
think think tank coin center
um coin centers other supporters include
vc pharma jason horowitz and crypto
exchange coin base
dorsey is no stranger to promoting
bitcoin having once claimed he believes
it will become the
single currency of the internet okay
did i match your energy there jack
absolutely killing it legend coin center
does fantastic work
if you have the means if you have the
heart if you have the desire
go help them out you can do everything i
think they sell some gear
i think they do events you can just
donate go help out coin center they're
awesome and jack
dorsey leading by action the executive
director said coin center has received
an incredibly generous gift of 1 million
from jack
uh we're speechless i like that okay
so 15 million 15 what am i saying
15 minimum wage will result in layoffs
one-third of small business owners say
one-third of small businesses anticipate
laying off workers if congress increases
the federal minimum wage to 15
an hour so uh a congressional budget
office analysis forecast that a fifteen
dollar minimum wage would lift
nine hundred thousand uh americans out
of poverty but result
in 1.4 million fewer jobs so it kind of
nullifies itself
no it's a net loss are you again are you
people
stupid they're literally talking about
we're going to help 900 000 people but
1.4 million people are going to lose
their jobs
what is going on allow the free
market to go who
cares what the minimum wage is people
who get minimum wage
if the free market is allowed to persist
they would actually get paid more than
the minimum wage the problem with
setting a floor
is that all of these employers just
immediately go to a manipulated bottom
of the floor they know that
everyone there is just going to get paid
with the minimum wages if you remove the
minimum wage and allow the free market
to operate
prices or the price of the employee's
salary
or income would actually go up that's
how the spending don't work
because now through competition you get
a more efficient market it's a
manipulated market at the moment
what competition at mcdonald's because
what would happen is mcdonald's would
have to pay
some uh a rate that would be attractive
compared to burger king and chick-fil-a
and all these other ones
and so if you want the best uh talent
you'd have to increase your prices
to lure that talent to you right now
they don't have to do anything they all
just pay minimum wage it's a manipulated
market
so if you have a manipulated market they
don't have to increase
their rate the government gets to decide
when people get paid more money
it just sounds like a thorny problem
paulina and i may actually disagree on
this i'm not sure
but what i am going to say is that if
you raise the minimum wage to 15
an hour now we are seeing data that says
yes you will help 900 000 people but you
will screw 1.4 million people
it is a net loss you'll hurt more people
than you will help
and rather than do it we should come up
with a better solution that is more
driven by free market economics
rather than have the government come in
and demand
that you do something the government is
not the answer they will not solve your
problems think for yourself have
personal responsibility
individual liberties i promise you'll be
better off in life
go okay um
the 2021 ipo market is already on fire
six weeks into the new year with specs
leading the way spax have raised more
than 38 billion dollars a year to date
with an average of 296 million for 128
back ideas i can't believe this thing is
on fire i remember chamoth talking about
this like literally four years ago
and now it's like everywhere uh there's
gonna be more spats than good companies
duh two is when polina says spack i
think back to the
aflac commercials where the little duck
would walk around and be like
a flat uh three is that
uh when you have a was 128 stacks
that have raised 38 billion dollars
where they gonna put all the money
where are they gonna put all this money
you know what they're gonna do the spax
are about to do what the government did
last year the government bailed out a
bunch of bad companies we got zombie
companies we're literally
the companies suck they should go out of
business we should redistribute
the resources both intellectual and
financial capital to better
run companies but the government came in
they propped up the companies and they
saved all the garbage
companies now what we're seeing though
is that the specs are about to do the
same thing they have to do a deal
they're on a time horizon so they got to
get a deal done
so what are they going to do i can't get
a tier 1 deal done so i'll go to tier
two can't get a tier two deal done i'll
go to tier three
by the time they get to tier 27 and
they're literally buying your mom's
cooking
out of her kitchen and a spec and giving
her a bunch of money
you're gonna be like wow this is
overheated it's basically the equivalent
of 1999 when the taxi drivers were
trying to tell investors how to invest
their capital
do not proceed without taking lots and
lots of caution
say yeah aflac okay um
okay so this is so funny mcdonald's
customers lit a revolt uh so many
complaints that mcdonald's took away
high c orange drink like hic
oh it's on there um that it's it's
bringing it back
after a nearly four-year absence from
soda fountains
wow it's how you gonna take away the
high c
and mcdonald said its return was
prompted by boisterous fans on social
media that have
passionately asked us to bring it back
over the years
don't mess with people's high c that's
what i'm going to say
if you want to mess with their money
you're going to be in trouble if you
want to mess with the juice you're going
to be in trouble
don't mess with people's high c if you
mess with people's high c
they're going to light you up on social
media rule number one a corporate
uh what do they call it communication
don't mess with people's high c
all right ready to ask lunch money
hashtag ask alan in the comments
daniel welch what would be your dream
vacation together
for me it is mars i'm kidding
um i'll just leave you there kid show
leave your butt there no for me it would
be lake como i love that place
we've been there i know again oh all
right yeah
that one's good for me too no no one
more okay
this is no but i just look like this
because i'm not going to argue with you
today because we got to go
i didn't even notice um this comes from
moist uh what a name
it's not really a question he just says
day one of commenting on lunch money
until bob gives me an internship are you
gonna give me moist
if you comment every day for 90 days
no no for 90 days if you make it 90 days
and you don't forget a single day
i'll do a call with you i'm not
guaranteeing you that i'm gonna do
anything
but i will do a call with you after
you've left a comment every day for 90
days
i'll do a call and if you're legit then
we'll talk but if you miss one day
you're done and by the way if you can't
go back
24 hours afterwards and then leave the
comments so what was the hour increment
he has to leave
the comment in the first 24 hours before
we post the next one
well we post the next more than 24 hours
sometimes but yeah moist we're gonna see
how
moist we really are all right that's it
for lunch but we'll see you guys
tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but eight point
six percent is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends